on en parle parfois comme de l'autre
pandémie la grippe aviaire cette année
elle fait des ravages pendant les
élevages commerciaux que chez les
oiseaux sauvages des mammifères sont
même atteints mais pourquoi un tel degré
de contamination voyez les explications
et une mise en garde certaines images
peuvent être troublantes
chaque automne il parcourt de très
longues distances et se déplacent par
milliers vers le sud ces oiseaux
migrateurs transportent maintenant un
bagage dangereux le virus H5 N1 une
souche de l'influenza à vierge hautement
pathogène et plus contagieuse que jamais
ce sont les virus qui évoluent sans
cesse le manifestement des face à un
virus qui a une capacité d'installation
de la faune sauvage qui est nettement
plus fort et on le voit tout simplement
avec le nombre et la diversité des
oiseaux sauvages les oiseaux marins des
rapaces des oiseaux aquatiques qui sont
touchés
quand on parle de spécialistes dans le
domaine
environ le J et en écologie et tout ça
ils nous disent ben regarder avec les
changements climatiques depuis quelques
années on a des oiseaux sauvages qui
dans leur site de nidification était en
fait séparés l'un de l'autre en ce que
maintenant il se rend compte
ces rencontres ont des effets
dramatiques sur des populations
d'oiseaux sauvages comme les fous de
bassins
la grippe aviaire des semousser les
élevages de volailles partout sur la
planète Asie Afrique Europe Amérique du
Nord
aux États-Unis 50 millions de volailles
ont été abattus en un an la France
traverse elle aussi la pire éclosion de
grippe aviaire de son histoire avec plus
de 20 millions d'oiseaux abattus
le H5 N1 frappe les élevages de la
Bretagne les Pays de la Loire et de la
Vendée
c'est dans cette région que les
producteurs ont été le plus fortement
touchés des producteurs comme Christian
Drouin au mois de janvier on a eu
quelques cas qui s'est arrêté sa reprise
donc fin février et ça s'est rapproché
au tout autour de chez moi très vite
deux semaines plus tard la grippe
aviaire s'invite chez l'éleveur de
poulet et le 17 mars je pensais avoir
des suspicions quelques morts dans dans
l'élevage le vétérinaire sanitaire est
venu bon avant d'avoir fait les
prélèvements il m'a dit que je suis à
peu près sûr que c'est la grippe aviaire
et ensuite ça a été très vite
et ça a été d'une violence vraiment
extrême
on voit les animaux en forme deux heures
après ils sont morts ça les prend très
très vite on est incapable de prédire
comment ça va évoluer
en vendez le virus contamine alors une
quarantaine d'élevage par jour
les services vétérinaires et les centres
des caressages de la région sont
dépassés par les événements et
complètement débordé
on nous a dit un peu en off mais on nous
a dit la seule solution vous fermez la
ventilation de votre bâtiment toute une
nuit et après vous ramassez les cadavres
dans les jours qui suivent et on les
enterre sur les exploitations
en trois jours à peine le virus sème la
dévastation dans son élevage il n'a pas
le choix il doit euthanasier lui-même
ses 14000 volailles
[Musique]
moi je suis rentré à la maison j'étais
me coucher j'étais dans le noir j'étais
complètement à massourdi
je dis mais c'est pas possible et
j'avais jamais vécu un truc comme ça et
mes voisins m'ont dit la même chose et
c'est complètement ahurissant sachant
qu'on peut rien faire
on prenait les nouvelles chez chacun
est-ce que ça va toi oui est-ce que tu
as besoin de quelque chose est-ce que tu
veux que je vienne t'aider le monde
paysan reste un monde où on parle pas
peu en tout cas et où on garde les
choses pour nous dans des cas de crise
comme ça ça semble pas du tout une bonne
idée de garder les choses pour soi quoi
le mieux c'est d'en parler même si ça
sort mal fausse le dire
le virus n'a pas épargné Étienne
Blanchard l'épidémie de grippe aviaire
la forcer à enfermé ses poulets dans ses
bâtiments qu'à peine 30 mètres séparent
le H5 N1 est tout de même parvenu à
s'infiltrer dans un des deux poulailler
aujourd'hui Pascal c'est chaud de la
Confédération paysanne vient le soutenir
et le jour de les envoyer à l'abattoir
en fait et bien il commençait à avoir
quelques morts dans le bâtiment il y
avait une trentaine de morts le
vétérinaire est venu ils ont ils ont
fait les autopsies et c'était la grippe
aviaire
en cinq jours Étienne Blanchard a perdu
4000 poulets
ne rentre plus dans ton bâtiment et puis
on attend que tout le monde meurt
il a dû patienter 10 jours avant que
l'équipe des carrissage Vienne
finalement récupérer les cadavres
de ça désorganiser tout le système avoir
autant de cadavres autant de
contaminations à gérer certains éleveurs
ont eu leurs animaux pendant 10 12 voire
15 jours dans les bâtiments avant de
pouvoir les ramasser
le plus compliqué pour les éleveurs ça a
été un certain moment que il y avait que
50% des animaux de morts les 50%, il
fallait les états nazier
en deux mois seulement la grippe aviaire
s'est développée de manière virulente
dans la région près d'un élevage sur
deux a été touché la proximité des
fermes a permis au virus de se propager
plus facilement
là ici il y a un élevage enfin il y a
une ferme avec de la volaille tous les
kilomètres donc forcément si on a un qui
là l'autre l'attrape aussi
dans les zones densité c'est très
compliqué de maîtriser le virus et on le
voit en France on le voit partout dans
les grands pays atteints qui ont de je
dirais une production avicole importante
au Canada le H5 N1 est d'abord apparu
sur la côte atlantique au printemps avec
l'arrivée des oies sauvages
puis il s'est rapidement propagé d'un
océan à l'autre
on est dans une situation où le virus
est exceptionnel on n'a jamais vu ça
avant on est dans un éclosion qu'on a
jamais vécu non plus avant d'une telle
ampleur
Manon rassicot fait partie de la cellule
de crise nationale de l'Agence
canadienne d'inspection des aliments
elle surveille de près l'immigration des
oiseaux sauvages pour mieux se préparer
à faire face aux éventuelles foyers
d'infection
[Musique]
en 2022 l'agence a fait abattre plus de
4 millions 650 000 oiseaux dans les
élevages de volailles du pays entre
autres un million 400 000 en Alberta un
million 180 000 en Colombie-Britannique
700 000 en Ontario 530 000 au Québec
comment le virus s'est-il propagé dans
les élevages commerciaux
des hypothèses sont sur la table
d'abord certains élevages ont accès à
l'extérieur et ont des contacts directs
avec la sauvagine
d'autres se trouvent à proximité de plan
d'eau où les fientes laissées par les
oiseaux sauvages contiennent une forte
charge virale le virus peut alors
survivre dans l'environnement pendant
des mois
que ce soit une étang donc un étang et
que les oiseaux avaient accès à l'étang
à proximité d'une rivière à proximité
d'un lac donc les élevages qui se
situeraient proches d'un cours d'eau
pour être plus à risque là d'être en
contact avec les oiseaux sauvages
le H5 N1 pourrait aussi se disperser
dans la poussière et dans l'air autour
des zones d'élevage
mais sur une centaine de mètres
peut-être 200 300 mètres avec des forts
et un milieu très poussiéreux on peut
avoir des conditions qui favoriseraient
à ce moment-là le déplacement dans l'air
de certaines particules
[Musique]
mais ce qui pose le plus grand risque
c'est l'activité autour des fermes les
mouvements de personnels de véhicules et
le transport des oiseaux
c'est une industrie sur roue c'est
vraiment une expression qu'on entend
souvent parce qu'il y a beaucoup de
déplacements on vient chercher des œufs
que sur des autres consommation des
zones d'incubation on les envoie au
pouvoir on les envoie dans les sites de
classement il va avoir des déplacements
même d'oiseaux parce que on part avec un
site avec plus d'oiseaux puis
éventuellement à mesure qui grossissent
on va les amener vers un autre site
[Musique]
quand l'influenza à vierge s'introduit
dans un bâtiment l'agence intervient
sans tarder donc en termes de d'impact
sur nos ressources c'est majeur c'est
vraiment une coordination là assez
spectaculaire en terme de mesure
d'urgence
en avril 2022 l'agence intervient chez
canard du lac Bron en Estrie où la
présence de beerus est confirmée
aussitôt des mesures de quarantaine et
une zone de protection sont mises en
place autour des bâtiments on empêche le
déplacement des oiseaux afin de limiter
la propagation du virus finalement près
de 200 000 canards sont euthanasiés et
400 milleux d'incubation sont détruits
on va procéder à l'euthanasie en
considérant évidemment des normes de
bien-être animal
la majorité des cas on va procéder à une
des peuplements par CO2 donc le gaz
carbonique
pour disposer des carcasses l'agence
privilégie le compostage à l'extérieur
ou à l'intérieur des bâtiments
sur un lit de copeaux de bois on dépose
les cadavres d'oiseaux les œufs et la
litière contaminée puis on y ajoute de
l'eau pour favoriser l'activité
bactérienne on empile successivement en
andain d'autres couches qu'on recouvre
finalement de copeaux lorsque la
température du compost dépasse les 37
degrés Celsius durant 6 jours
consécutifs le virus devient inactif
trois mois plus tard ce compost peut
être répandu sur les terres agricoles ou
servir de fertilisant c'est quelque
chose qui fonctionne bien qui est vert
parce que le produit du compost peut
même être utilisé peut être mis dans
l'environnement d'une façon sécuritaire
alors oui c'est ça qui est favorisé
quand on a des grands élevages
c'est tout le contraire en Europe le
compostage est interdit
en vendez les oiseaux sont enterrés à la
ferme
les autorités sanitaires ont aussi créé
d'immenses fausses temporaires pour
enfouir les carcasses
pour des raisons de salubrité on a
recouvert les cadavres de chaux projetés
par des canons
des charniers devenus tristement
nécessaires et qui illustrent la gravité
de la crise qui a frappé la France au
printemps 2022
[Musique]
cette année la grippe aviaire a provoqué
une hécatombe dans beaucoup d'élevages
notamment ceux de canards si bien qu'on
cherche de toute urgence une solution et
la vaccination serait l'une d'elle
[Musique]
en bocage en Vendée la production de
foie gras fait partie du patrimoine et
une véritable trajet dit frappe cette
tradition ancestrale dessine les
troupeaux de volailles et deschirent les
familles
depuis 1989 Christophe Teillet exploite
avec sa conjointe une production de
transformation de canards une entreprise
prospère mais le vent a tourné dans
l'atelier de gavage les 634 sont vides
donc nous c'est des canards qui avaient
la grippe aviaire avant d'arriver dans
notre bâtiment
mais il a fallu tout euthanasier au bout
de quatre jours de gavage le producteur
n'est pas seul la Vendée compte plus de
1000 fermes de canards gras et la
situation est plus dramatique encore
chez d'autres gavers de la région quand
on voit des bâtiments avec des 10 000
canards de morts c'est vraiment agréable
comme on a de la chance qu'il y en ait
pas qui soit suicidé dans notre
entourage parce que il y avait vraiment
des gens qui étaient dans le dans le
fond
quand on a ramassé leur volaille chez
eux on voulait même pas qu'il soit ici
parce que c'était
vous avez le moral à zéro
l'industrie du canard est fortement
ébranlée par la pandémie de grippe
aviaire qui sévit depuis un an pour deux
raisons
[Musique]
deuxièmement ils sont déplacés alors
l'éclatement des foyers en France c'est
arrivé quand on a déplacé des animaux
par exemple pour le gavage alors pour le
foie gras
le problème avec ce virus c'est qu'il
peut être asymptomatique chez les
canards
depuis des temps immémoriaux le canard a
des rapports particuliers avec les virus
influences il en est un peu le réservoir
donc les producteurs de canard sont
victimes en quelque sorte de ses
propriétés biologiques du canard
alors on peut avoir des oiseaux qui
sentent tout à fait normaux en pleine
santé mais ils sont déjà en train
d'expliquer des milliards de particules
virales
et quand les symptômes de la grippe
aviaire finissent par se manifester les
canards souffrent de problèmes
neurologiques
on a décidés
de la posture des oiseaux et ensuite une
mortalité qui va se déclencher et
quelquefois la mortalité peut être très
faible
chez les poulets et les dindes les
signes sont différents ils perdent de
l'appétit la ponte diminue et un taux de
mortalité élevé peut survenir en 24
heures à peine
[Musique]
en France les risques de diffusion du
virus sont nettement plus élevés dans
les ondes de grandes densité les
autorités sanitaires ont forcé les
producteurs à mettre fin à l'élevage en
plein air des volailles c'est une mesure
parmi d'autres qui freine en quelque
sorte le risque d'introduction de virus
depuis la faune sauvage vers les
élevages mais il ne fonctionne que s'il
est associé à des mesures de biosécurité
classique très très fortes
et ensuite il fonctionne si vous n'avez
pas une je dirais une charge virale dans
l'environnement très forte
[Musique]
le producteur de volaille cherche un
remède efficace pour sortir de cette
crise et la vaccination est l'une des
solutions envisagées la vaccination est
très mal vue au niveau international par
les pays importateurs donc tous les
grands pays exportateurs ont toujours
manié la vaccination en Europe aux
États-Unis
et c'est vrai que la situation
européenne et nord-américaine change
cette appréciation
le sujet fait d'ailleurs l'objet de
discussion au sein de l'Union européenne
des vaccins pour les poulets et les
dindes sont actuellement à laisser en
Europe en France Jean-Luc Guérin dirige
deux projets pilotes de vaccination des
canards parce que je peux dire à date
c'est que les essais se déroulent bien
donc ça va nous permettre en tout cas
d'avoir une information etc c'est pas la
solution c'est une solution
complémentaire en d'autres termes on ne
peut pas se reposer sur la vaccination
et dire ben on va finalement la biosé on
arrête la surveillance de tester ça ce
serait extrêmement dangereux
d'autant plus dangereux que le virus se
transmet aux oiseaux marins aux oiseaux
de proie ainsi qu'aux mammifères ce
qu'il faut s'inquiéter qui puisse y
avoir une transmission à d'autres
mammifères on a beaucoup de défense de
surveillance présentement sur les mêmes
femmes sur tous les fortes
au Québec depuis le début 2022 une
centaine de phoques ont été trouvés
morts dans l'estuaire du Saint-Laurent
un tour de mortalité anormalement élevé
les analyses ont démontré que plusieurs
de ces phoques avaient contracté la
grippe aviaire
au Canada et aux Etats-Unis on a aussi
découvert des renards des moufettes des
ratons laveurs des ours et des visons
atteints du virus H5 N1
il se serait infecté en mangeant des
carcasses d'oiseaux morts
on peut voir aussi des signes
neurologiques c'est à dire des signes
nerveux l'animal peut avoir la tête
traversée peut avoir des tremblements un
incontination
peut avoir la tête penchée sur un côté
de la difficulté à se déplacer
certains craignent que la grippe aviaire
puisse éventuellement infecter l'humain
à ce jour la transmission du virus aux
humains est faible les rares cas connues
touchent des travailleurs qui étaient en
contact T3 avec des volailles contaminés
pour l'instant il y a pas de raison de
paniquer mais c'est une possibilité là
le risque est loin d'être heureux
l'origine de ce virus là ces enceintes
ont un certain talent pour devenir zones
c'est-à-dire avoir éventuellement la
capacité de se transmettre de l'animal à
l'être humain
si on laisse au virus l'opportunité de
se répliquer à travers plusieurs espèces
comme ça éventuellement on pourrait
devenir une des espèces
actuellement une autre vague de h5neu se
dessine au pays c'est automne dans les
quatre provinces de l'Ouest canadienne
on trouve 88 foyers d'éclosions le
Québec est l'Ontario en
contrepectivement 10 et 11
dès qu'on a une suspicion il y a plus
rien qui sort puis si le diagnostic est
confirmé tout doit être abattu le plus
vite possible
pour des raisons bien être animales puis
pour diminuer la possibilité de
propagation du virus
c'est le drame que vive deux producteurs
de volaille de Saint-Alphonse de Granby
en Estrie en octobre dernier le H5 N1
frappe fort
45000 poulets et 30 000 poules pondeuses
sont euthanasies sur un premier site
d'élevage puis 11500 dindons sont
abattus dans cet autre ferme
[Musique]
près de deux mois plus tard ce tas de
compost fait avec les carcasses témoigne
du passage du virus une cicatrice qui
marque encore la productrice de dindon
Marie-Christine parent quand tu
souhaites
des aventures comme ça pour elle et sa
mère tous s'écroule du jour au lendemain
quand le virus H5 N1 s'introduit dans un
des deux poulailler l'Agence canadienne
d'inspection des aliments fait aussi tôt
euthanasier le troupeau et impose un
protocole de nettoyage complexe avant la
relance des activités une fois que les
oiseaux sont sortis à ce moment-là c'est
l'étape du nettoyage à sec il faut
nettoyer les installations dans les
moindres recoins
fallait vraiment laver là et les prises
d'air à l'extérieur les ventilateurs
l'agence considère aussi que le parquet
du poulailler pose un risque de
contamination pour éviter le retour du
virus la productrice fait changer les
planchers enfin que les planchers sont
pas changés je peux pas avoir
l'approbation du nettoyage complété ce
qui m'empêche de passer à l'étape de
désinfection et après ça une fois que la
désinfection est approuvée mais là on va
pouvoir réintroduire des des oiseaux là
14 jours après on va rentrer le 10
janvier
la production va reprendre mais
Marie-Christine appréhendent le pire
beaucoup de beaucoup d'inquiétudes par
rapport à l'avenir aussi
[Musique]
et elle a raison de s'inquiéter les
producteurs de volaille ne sont sans
doute pas au bout de leur peine
[Musique]
dans le prochain mois on devrait
s'attendre à d'autres foyers donc le
risque est assez élevé ça devrait
diminuer avec l'arrivée de l'hiver et
puis au printemps prochain on est à très
haut risque que ça prenne
[Musique]
en France la situation s'est dégradée
cet automne avec l'apparition de
nouveaux foyers d'éclosion malgré tout
Christian Drouin a relancé la production
de poulet mais cette fois-ci avec la
peur au ventre des animaux pour les voir
mourir comme ça c'est vraiment
traumatisant et surtout la crainte c'est
que ça revienne des fermes situées près
de chez Christophe Teillet ont été
récemment victimes du virus H5 N1 ce qui
le force à reporter le redémarrage des
opérations
en place c'est que ça recommence mais
sinon on doit recommencer euthanaser des
animaux dans nos bâtiments comme on l'a
fait en février mars là non non
je suis inquiet globalement sur le
caractère soutenable de ces crises donc
la situation et effectivement
extrêmement sérieuse elle va le rester
pendant des mois des années on sait que
pendant des années on va avoir ce risque
là on ne va pas se débarrasser du virus
quel que soit le scénario donc on est
vraiment sur un risque majeur
[Musique]